Step aside, oil pulling - there’s a new
trend in town, and it’s… buttered coffee?
Sounds... rich.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and every
week, it seems there’s a hot new trend we
should all be getting on board with.
Earlier this month, I came across an interesting
article on something called buttered coffee.
It’s exactly what it sounds like, and while
the idea of adding butter to your coffee might
sound a little too Paula Deen for some, a
lot of people out there swear by it.
Even doctors are touting its benefits, so
what’s the deal?
What is buttered coffee, and why is it good
for you?
Well, here’s the official recipe.
You take 1 cup of black coffee, add 1-2 tbsp
of unsalted grass-fed butter, and 1-2 tbsp
of MCT oil.
Blend until frothy.
MCT stands for medium-chain triglycerides,
and it’s basically a processed mixture of
fats that naturally occur in coconut and palm
kernel oils.
MCT oil is more rapidly digested and metabolized
than other types of fats, so a lot of studies
have touted it as a weight loss supplement
- it increases your body’s ability to burn
energy, while decreasing its fat storage.
It’s a key component of buttered coffee,
but the people who swear by it, also say that
the kind of butter you use, is equally as
important.
It MUST be unsalted, and it must be grass-fed
- just organic is not enough.
Same goes for the coffee - ideally, it should
be organic, single-origin beans.
Obviously, this can get pretty expensive - but
is it worth it?
Well, to a lot of people, it is.
In addition to curbing hunger and potentially
aiding in weight loss, people also say it
helps with energy and focus, gives greater
mental clarity, and sustains your coffee buzz
for longer - up to 6 hours - while eliminating
the post-caffeine crash.
It also curbs the jittery side effects and
the acid-stomach feeling you get from drinking
straight coffee.
And since it’s technically served frothed,
a lot of people say it just tastes like a
fattier latte - which doesn’t actually sound
all that bad.
Now depending on how much butter and MCT oil
you use, a single cup of this stuff contains
anywhere from 200-500 calories, and 45-65
grams of fat - which is 100% of your daily
recommended intake of saturated fat.
So how can something that bad, be good for
you?
This is where it gets tricky.
If you were to add buttered coffee to your
daily routine, you would theoretically gain
anywhere from 20-30 lbs per year.
So it’s generally recommended that you use
it as a meal replacement, and not a supplement.
Assuming you agree that good fats are something
your body needs, then that’s fine.
But even people who believe that saturated
fats get “unfairly demonized” say they
should be eaten WITH a meal, not AS the meal.
There are also people out there who say that
even if buttered coffee’s not that bad for
you, a traditional breakfast is still way
more nutritious.
And depending on what you’re eating, that
could be entirely true.
Consuming that much butter, can lead to high
cholesterol - and especially so, if you’re
not adjusting other aspects of your diet to
accommodate.
Still, I’m a little surprised by how few
doctors seem to warn against it altogether.
Most nutritionists say if you wanna try it
out, go right ahead.
But you should probably get your cholesterol
checked first, to make sure it’s normal.
Personally, I was a little grossed out by
the whole idea of this at first, but I’ll
admit - after reading up on it, it does intrigue
me.
So I thought we could do a little experiment.
If this episode gets 5,000 likes - then I
will try buttered coffee for a whole week,
and we’ll upload a follow-up video of my
experience, good or bad.
Deal?
Deal.
I’m sure some of you out there have tried
it as well, and if you have - we’d love
to know what you think!
Just let us know in the comments, and as always
- thank you guys for watching!